[موسيقى]
نشق طريقنا وسط هذا الدمار في هذا المبنى
الذي عرف بالقلعه قبل اشهر فقط كان حصنا
ومقرا لمعارضين ايرانيين لكنه لم يكن
منيعا ضد ضربات النظام الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني
اقدم واهم الاحزاب الايرانيه المعارضه من
هنا من قلعته في قوي في كردستان العراق
كان يدير عمليات السياسيه وما تتبعه من
منظمات طلابيه شبابيه ونسائيه لكن هذا
المقر كثيرا ما كان يتعرض لضربات ايرانيه
ازدادت الضربات مع المظاهرات الايرانيه
الاخيره واتهام ايران لهذه الاحزاب باداره
وقياده المظاهرات التي انطلقت في ايران
منذ اشهر ولم تهدا الى غايه الان اذا هذه
بقايا احد الصواريخ الايرانيه يقول السيد
اماجو هو قيادي في الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الايراني المعارض بان هذه
القطع الصغيره هي قطع معدنيه الهدف منها
هو ايقاع اكبر قدر من القتلى في هذه
الضربات الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
تم قصف هذا المكان ومخيم اللاجئين
والمدارس بصواريخ النظام كانت المدرسه
تستضيف 220 طالبا في غضون ذلك تصف النظام
ايضا حزب كوما وحزب الحريه الكردستاني قصف
النظام الاحزاب الثلاثه في نفس الوقت قصفت
هذه القلعه بسبعه وثلاثين صاروخا بالاضافه
الى طائرات مسيره انتحاريه
[موسيقى]
اعين النظام الايراني ليست فقط فعاله
سياسي وعسكريين ديمقراطي الكردستاني
والاحزاب الاخرى المعارضه وانما كذلك على
الجيل الجديد الذي ينشا بعيدا عن دعايه
المرشد والنظام الايراني هذه كانت مدرسه
مخصصه لاطفال اللاجئين الاكراد هنا في قوي
ولكنها تعرضت لقصف ايراني وهجرت منذ ذلك
الحين
[موسيقى]
استهداف مدرسه للاجئين ومواقع السكنيه في
كويسنجق او كويا وهذا الاسم الكردي
للمنطقه جعل السؤال عن الغايه الايرانيه
مشروعا اذكر الاحوال على سبيل لهم الى
البقاء في حاله استنفار دائمه
التي ترونها هنا تحرس مخيمات اللاجئين
والعائلات الموجوده قواعدنا العسكريه
الرئيسيه قريبه من الحدود وهذا المكان
موقع مدني لتقليل مخاطر الهجمات بالصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره وزعنا قوه البيشمركه
للدفاع عن المخيمات
يجزم المعارضون الايرانيون انجيلا يتهجى
الحريه والديمقراطيه اكثر ازعاجا للمرشد
ونظامه الذي يسعى لخنق اصواتهم ومطالبهم
مطالب تردد صداها في مظاهرات ايران
الاخيره
ساره بنعيشوبا العربيه كويستنج كردستان
العراق